what do you think the most important
skill is
for an entrepreneur um in order to be
successful
i've thought about this a lot lately
yeah i would say have daddy issues
what let's say have daddy issues number
one uh i think have dad issues because
you want to prove yourself
so it doesn't have to be a dad issue
i'll tell you the thing i think is the
most important skill or give it two but
i think the people that have had some
chips on their shoulder and have
something to prove has definitely
excelled because they've like i've got
to get through this hard part
um and you know i wanted my dad to
to acknowledge me because i felt like i
didn't get enough attention when i was
younger and then as i started making
money i was i thought that would get the
attention it didn't
uh and so eventually you have to like
yourself and things like that but i
definitely think having some
levels of that like steve jobs was
adopted i think that definitely impacted
a little bit
uh of his success but i would say in
terms of like actual skills that people
could practice and i can give people
tips on how to do it
number one is persistence it is
a grind
sometimes it's easier than others but
like i'm doing full-time youtube there's
days where i launch a video with our
team and i'm like
i'm the greatest superstar out there and
there's days like today we put a video
no one watches it
right and it's being able to go
on the next day so i say persistence i
tell people to do the coffee challenge
that's kind of what i've gotten known
for which is
go out and get rejected you go out
so you go out when you get your coffee
coffee mug and you say
you go to starbucks or whatever in
canada dunkin donuts or tim hortons
and uh you say hey i want 10 off and you
can do this when you buy anything and
they say no
or maybe they say yes who cares the
point is you get rejected
and that really builds up your your kind
of fear muscle but also your persistence
muscle because you're like all right
well i'm gonna do it again
i'm gonna do it again and eventually
you're like you know you you talk a lot
you help guys with dating and advice and
women a lot of it is like
all right keep going it's fine so i
think persistence you know my favorite
quotes my friend says persistence beats
resistance
uh so i'd say that's number one that i
love and the second thing i'd say as an
entrepreneur
uh personally is really a follow-through
i can't tell you how many sales i've
done in my life and i've done millions
of dollars in sales from
actual sales as well as online sales
that just because of the follow-up
follow-up email
follow-up call follow-up text follow-up
what what's that message
has closed the deal uh and so many
people email me like
our email i'm sure you get emails of the
time hey richard i'd love to do
something with you
never follow up so i'd still i owe you a
follow-up actually for the book notes
but it's still in my to do so i'm going
to do it
and it's just like you got to follow up
on your things and i think that that
separates a lot of winners from losers
i think losers send one instagram dm to
some girl
or one you know one message to some
company they want to partner with
and they call it a day they're like oh
it didn't work it's like did you really
want it if you want it
follow up um i've i've um
you know like i mentioned i've thought a
lot about this and i think if i were to
like
distill it down to one thing i would say
having having the ability to solve
problems
um gumption's very important to you know
like having that grit like you talked
about
but i find that when you start up a
business it's it's really just a
sequence of
problems that you have to deal with and
if you can get good at
finding solutions to problems um you can
get good at business
i mean it's the same thing with women
it's like how you were talking about the
rule and dealing with rejection there's
there's a large demographic of men out
there today
that don't know how to deal with
rejection with women and
i mean they would be no good at starting
up a business or
doing sales calls and stuff like that at
the same time but i think that's an
important
um thing to mention too um i like the
resourcefulness one i definitely think
that's that's a great one
you